filling these five buckets first
one is your knowledge it's important
context here as well this first bucket
of knowledge is is always growing bigger
there's more knowledge to acquire it's
like a bucket that is increasing in size
as more knowledge is available first
bucket is your knowledge the second
bucket is your skills Nothing in life
can ever empty these two buckets the the
remaining three buckets that I'm going
to describe can be emptied things can go
wrong you can get fired from your job
professional earthquakes but these first
two buckets no one can ever empty them
your knowledge your skills and skills
are really applied knowledge so when you
learn something and then you apply it we
call it a skill which is kind of what
we've been talking about with like
knowing something but then doing it is
completely different you can read about
exercise but then doing knowing how to
do the squats and stuff comes from the
application of the knowledge which is a
skill these are the most important
buckets in your life because when these
overflow they fill the other three
buckets of your resources um your
network and your reputation now these
three things can can these buckets can
any time and if you're young and you're
thinking okay which job should I take
you should you should make the decision
through this Frame because I talk about
one of my team members in the very early
stages of my entrepreneurial career who
decided to leave our company because he
was offered a great job title and a big
paycheck which is reputation and
resources but he hadn't filled his
skills and knowledge bucket he' kind of
like managed to convince someone that he
was capable of being a CEO of a very big
company even though he hadn't didn't
have the Knowledge and Skills and it
kind of it's quite obvious what happens
there life will catch you out if you
don't have the Knowledge and Skills to
meet the situation you're in what I'm
fortunate for is in my life I spent
maybe three to four years working in
call centers picking up the phone
calling Dorothy at 900 p.m. to sell like
you know artificial grass Windows Doors
conservatories kitchens because it
filled up these this Knowledge and
Skills bucket profoundly I could have
gone and got a more glamorous job but
choosing a job at that early age that
was focused on my Knowledge and Skills
not that paid me more or that had higher
status amongst my friends is the reason
why I was able to launch businesses and
do well at a young age so I would just
impress upon people to really focus and
prioritize those first two buckets
especially when you're young and
especially when they're empty hey
friends thank you so much for watching
if you enjoyed this clip then click here
for the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day bye-bye